even if someone sucks absolutely sucks  I'll still tip on I'll still give him a  fat tip this cheat I wanted to be on his  side I'm white I tip no matter what  because it's in my culture what's funny  is as he's gotten richer he tips worse  and worse it's really it's a really  interesting phenomenon it's a really  interesting phenomena  15  once in my life  wow  you're playing the game you're playing a  game what are you making up these  Shenanigans cause you got defensive and  you're projecting no he doesn't tip what  do you tip at least one  close pandemic I swear to God host  pandemic this guy's never attempt 20 in  his entire [ __ ] life  cause somebody's lying  is a little low for somebody rich I do  more than that  take it off